ils veulent faire entendre leur colère
les psychologues manifestent aujourd'hui
un peu partout en france
ils dénoncent la dégradation de leurs
conditions de travail largement
sollicités depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire ils étaient nombreux devant le
ministère de la santé à paris
on voit ça avec notre reporter
guillemard aussi cette journée de
manifestation cette journée de grève
elle était assez exceptionnel assez
inhabituel pour cette profession il est
en effet assez rare de voir les
psychologues se rassemblaient manifester
de la sorte privé-public ensemble et
pourtant ils y ont répondu massivement
ces psychologues à cet appel du 18 juin
lancé par de très nombreux syndicats et
organisations représentatives
ils ont été des centaines à se
rassembler ici devant le ministère de la
santé où une délégation syndicale a été
reçue par des officiels écouter on
souhaite délibérément le retrait de la
loi et que les conditions de l'entrée
dans ce qui a été écrit ne nous convient
absolument pas entrer dans des
conditions déplorables avec un manque de
moyens et non reconnaissance de notre
parcours universitaire ni des recherches
en cours et avec une médicalisation de
notre profession qui nous enlèverait
notre capacité à penser par nous-mêmes
c'est une perte d'autonomie c'est aussi
délibérément un manque d'indépendance
pour notre profession et ça nous soumet
un fonctionnement dont on n'a même pas
été consultés avant que les choses se
mettent en place les mécontentements
vise en particulier une absence ou une
difficulté à reconnaître la spécificité
la compétence des psychologues on l'a vu
à travers une série de mesures
ça repose sur des dispositifs
réglementaires et des forces de pression
de reconnaissance de la profession
profession des qualifiés profession mal
reconnus par des taux de rémunération
qui sont in entendable alors que depuis
un an dans lego nation que nous
conduisions nous avions dit et redit que
les tarifs qui ont finalement été
proposée ne pouvait pas être un cadre de
reconnaissance pour nous nous l'avions
dit d'emblée pourtant c'est ce qui est
ressorti alors vous l'avez entendu les
revendications sont nombreuses et les
psychologues compte bien obtenir gain de
cause
en attendant eh bien ils rejoignent les
rangs de la contestation des personnels
de nombreuses professions de santé